[Musique]
si je vous dis Louise laabbé est-ce que
ça vous dit quelque chose le nom me dit
quelque chose mais il associer une
personne une fonction non et qu'est-ce
que vous pensez des noms de rues de
places qui portent des noms de femmes
bah écoutez moi je pense que c'est une
bonne chose comme ça ça représente
l'ensemble de la société tout le
personne exclu bonsoir madame bonsoir
vous habité donc rue Louise Labé c'est
ça oui rue Louise Labé apparemment on
n'est pas tellement représenté nous les
femmes dans les rues au niveau des rues
donc là au moins on représente une rue
qui un nom de femme quoi ça me fait
penser un peu à un historien qui disait
que en général les hommes règnent mais
les femmes
[Musique]
gouvernent bonjour à toutes et tous et
bienvenue à Amboise rue Louise
[Musique]
Labé poétesse incontournable de la
Renaissance né en 1524 à Lyon Louise
laabbé était évoqué jusqu'à ces
dernières années dans des spectacle dans
les jardins du
château Louise laabbé a bousculé les
idées du 16e siècle en évoquant l'amour
dans sa passion charnelle elle rond
radicalement avec les habitudes de son
époque pour elle la femme n'est plus
l'objet du désir masculin mais c'est
l'homme qui devient l'objet du désir
féminin
surnommé la belle Cordière en lien avec
le métier de son père et de son mari
Louise Labbé a eu la chance d'être la
seule femme avoir publié ses propres
œuvres de son
[Musique]
vivant depuis 33 ans Catherine Reyes
raconte l'histoire au château d'Amboise
elle m'attend afin de nous faire
découvrir l'histoire de ce bijou de la
[Musique]
Renaissance
bonjour Catherine bonjour et merci de
nous accueillir dans ce beau parc du
château d'Amboise ou et donc votre
rencontre avec la ville d'emboise et son
château vous parleriez d'une histoire
d'amour même je parlerai d'une rencontre
mais c'est une belle rencontre et une
une belle page d'histoire pour moi aussi
depuis le temps que que je suis là
d'autant que le château d'Amboise est
chargé d'histoire de femme non bien sûr
première femme importante dans
l'histoire du château d'Amboise on peut
dire que c'est Anne de Bretagne qui va
être deux fois reinees de France qui va
passer partie de sa vie à Amboise puis
après d'autres femmes vont venir la mère
de François prier Louise de Savoie avec
lui quand il était enfant la sœur de
François prier Marguerite Caine de
mdicis he beaucoup beaucoup de grandes
femmes de l'histoire sont venu et ont
vécu ici donc ont marqué le château de
leur empreinte et Louise Labbé dans tout
ça elle vous inspire quoi j'ai découvert
que c'était donc effectivement une
poétesse même si on n'a pas écrit
beaucoup importante au 16e siècle hein
c'est la femme
moderne de l'époque et votre sentiment à
vous quant à l'idée de baptiser des rues
par des noms de femmes bah c'est bien il
y a autant de femmes importantes que
d'hommes même des femmes inconnues hein
moi j'habite dans une rue c'est c'est le
nom d'une rue de femme laquelle Camille
Claudel ben oui Camille Claudel
évidemment dont nous irons à la
rencontre au au château de lillette
voilà à très bientôt et puis en
attendant n'oubliez pas des fleurs des
cœurs des couleurs du bonheur même pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
peur